well let's jump to uh this this next
story which kind of feeds into this we
have this from the hill
hillary clinton said i would love to see
if trump quote
was talking to putin the day the
insurgents
invaded our capital what it's just
ridiculous
but it's all about playing to the tribal
politics
and finding the boogeyman to rally their
base and go after the other side
and the next story part of the same
story is that
clinton pelosi call for 911 style
commission
into the capital riot and putin's role
so there's no sign of de-escalation i
mean
let me read a little bit so we get some
context here they say there is strong
support in the congress for establishing
a 911 style commission to investigate
trump's ties to vladimir putin
and russian involvement in the capital
riot in an interview on clinton's
podcast you and me both released monday
pelosi made the revelation after the
2016 democratic presidential candidate
discussed her concerns
that the outgoing commander-in-chief was
compromised by the kremlin
we learned a lot about our system of
government over the last four years
with a president who disdains democracy
and as as you have said numerous times
has other agendas
what they all are i don't think we yet
know i hope historically we will find
out
who he's beholden to who pulls his
strings
the former secretary of state got
specific questioning whether he spoke to
putin
i would love to see if his phone records
i would love to see his phone records to
see whether he was talking to putin the
day
the insurgents invaded our capital we
now know that not just him but his
enablers
his accomplices his cult members have
the same disregard for democracy
asked by clinton whether the nation
needs a 911
911 type commission to investigate and
report everything they can pull together
pelosi said i do
as i said to him in the picture with my
blue suit as i was leaving
what i was saying to him as i was
pointing rudely at him with you mr
president all roads lead to putin
the top house democrat said at the
outset of a reply
going on to say she does not know what
putin has on him politically
financially or personally but what
happened last week was a gift to putin
because putin wants to undermine
democracy in our country
and throughout the world we had we had
the whole
mueller probe it was a 30 plus million
dollars spent
coming up with nothing and now here we
go again mueller probe 2.0 i mean
this is just like q anon paranoia level
stuff conspiracy theories made up
pretty much suggesting that that putin
was ordering donald trump during the
capital siege
how naive how insane how of how much of
a crazy person do you have to be to go
there based off absolutely no evidence
at all hyperbolic theorization
of the worst possible scenario that you
could imagine but yet again
pushing a very russian phobic uh kind of
narrative
russian phobic uh kind of policy that
we've seen
from from the previous administrations
we also have seen mitt romney call for
more russian sanctions today
so we're going to see another big pivot
towards a very aggressive foreign policy
against russia
against of course its major allies
within the entire world
and and why isn't this stuff banned you
know you know who doesn't like russia
succeeding
china oh yeah that's right well yeah
well they're
like they're they're like in a quasi
kind of alliance but they're also at
odds in certain aspects
historically as well but why isn't this
paranoia why isn't this fake news why
isn't this conspiracy theory
banned on on twitter or on facebook on
youtube hillary clinton should have her
podcast taken down immediately
for violations of terms and services and
spreading well
bad information that doesn't help anyone
and is based off no truth at all with no
evidence
we're not at that point where they're
banning podcasts yet but they're trying
so there's been a series of of articles
where they're like
podcasts are where the real
radicalization happens and they point
out that a bunch of podcasters had their
youtube channels banned or twitter
banned but they're still on itunes and
spotify so it's coming
but the bigger question is you know
twitter banned 70 000 people for be
for posting q related content not not
even outright conspiracy stuff it was
people
i believe for the most part in this
leaked video we got from project veritas
they were mostly talking about
the election you know voter fraud and
things like that
so twitter bans them but what about the
people who said the exact same thing
four years ago and are saying the exact
same thing now
the fact that we have someone like jack
dorsey and vijaya gaday
saying we accept this tribe's unhinged
conspiracy but not this one
to me it's like jack dorsey wants
people to kill each other and the reason
i say this and and the reason why i've
been very harsh on the man
is because i sat in front of him and
said if you keep doing what you are
doing
you will create civil unrest and
potentially some kind of civil war
and then i was like i'm building a van
get ready to bug out because of what's
happening in this country
and they laughed and said it was silly
and so dumb and i got emails from people
saying you're so silly you're so crazy
and then i got emails from people a year
ago saying man you were right
and i got emails from people different
people in the past couple of weeks being
like dude
i've got people tweeting at me now like
wow maybe tim was right about all this
yeah when you have billionaires in
silicon valley
telling american citizens you are not
allowed to participate
in this conversation but the ayatollah
can chinese ambassadors can lie and
smear our soldiers
and they can post pictures of australian
soldiers
slitting the throat of children they can
post that gra it was an artistic render
a render of it
that's allowed twitter allows this and
only after
massive outcry to do anything about it
but they will proactively purge people
on the right
recently there was a post from china
about why it was good
they're operating concentration camps
and they left it
and they told these journalists it does
not violate our rules and it was only
after basically everybody said dude
allowing china to post in favor of
concentration camps kind of messed up
they finally took it down they
proactively go after conservatives
think about how how dangerous this is
when you have an american citizen who is
expressing their opinion on their
political preference
you ban them for that preference then
you have an australian citizen go on
twitter
and say anything he wants and it
influences our elections
and they allow it eventually you're
going to get a bunch of angry americans
watching european australian or canadian
policies be running amok
on in our political discourse in our
news and they're cut out
they're going to lose it they already
nuked parlor
right and that's that's one of the
cascading effects is definitely going to
be the assault on free speech
and that is going to be one of those key
elements
that will bring about individual events
that then build again to that point
where we're really going to see a
problem but
it's interesting so a point of
perspective having been
you know spending 12 years in the
country of belarus which is just outside
of russia proper
um and basically you know it's like the
the they have a very awkward uh
relationship trying to be a small
independent nation but
so much of the russian news is so
anti-american you wouldn't believe it
it's
everybody does need the boogeyman and
you know we are theirs and sort of this
frenemy situation
uh but it'd be interesting to see how
the
the incoming administration what kind of
relationship they're going to try to
have
oh it's completely it's clearly
antagonistic to russia
at least it's favorable to china you
know in that regard try and prevent war
in the
in the pacific but that's not good
either what china is doing with the
uyghur camps
what they're doing with hong kong it is
it is what nightmares are made of well
it was also officially declared today
this is also news that happened
that china was declared to be committing
genocide by the united states especially
when it comes to
the uyghur muslim population so that
news also just happened today by the way
so we have the story here from cnn u.s
accuses china of genocide of uyghurs
and minority groups in xinjiang which
i'm probably pronouncing wrong
they say quote the genocide is ongoing
and we are witnessing the systematic
attempt to destroy uyghurs by the
chinese party state
u.s secretary of state mike pompeo said
in a statement on tuesday the last full
day of the trump administration
since at least march of 2017 local
authorities dramatically escalated their
decades-long campaign
of repression against uyghur muslims and
members of other ethnic and religious
minority groups including ethnic kha'zix
and ethnic kirk kurgs kirkus i'm sorry i
can't pronounce it properly
yeah kirkus the u.s state department has
previously estimated that the two
million uyghurs as well as
uh as well as well as members of other
muslim minority groups
have been detained in a sprawling
network of internment camps in the
region
former re-education camp detainees have
told cnn they experienced political
indoctrination
and abuse inside the camps such as food
and sleep deprivation and forced
injections
cnn reporting has also found that some
uyghur women were forced to use birth
control and undergo sterilization
as part of a deliberate attempt to push
down birth rates among minorities in
xinjiang
that's the level of depravity going on
in china so it is kind of worrying that
you know you have the binding transition
team which includes people who have been
favorable and defensive of china and now
they're trying to shift all the focus
onto russia
i i get it russia's you know we're
adversaries in
a manner of speaking but they're nowhere
near as big a threat as say china has
that's kind of being ignored yeah it's a
it'll be interesting because the real
threat comes when
china and russia decide
that they're going to unite and then
then you have a real problem
i mean we have the safety of having
borders that know there's no large army
that can come across
but well those canadians man you got to
watch out
when they started working with the
chinese military and doing drills
very near the u.s border but china and
russia have already joined in quasi
partnerships economically
also financially with trade and also
militarily by doing many military
exercises together geopolitically
they're usually on the same side when it
comes to iran
syria and they kind of have a weird
relationship where historically they
were at odds with each other and
it's still kind of tense but they do
have a mutual common enemy and that of
course
is the united states so if there would
be a conflict with one
there would be a conflict most likely
with another in one way or
another with either support or actual
even
bigger presence of a bigger alliance
together yeah absolutely and we
you know we're powerful enough that we
can defend ourselves right
say today right now but all these
internal struggles is what's going to
bring others
and we get to that point of you know
unrest or to the point of civil war well
then you can expect our borders to
look i see foreign troops i was bullish
three years ago i'm bullish
now you know it was it was years ago i
was watching the political tensions
escalate between antifa
and and groups like the proud boys and i
was talking about my fear
of a coming civil war and i guess what a
lot of people didn't realize is that my
experience was coming from occupy wall
street
i watched hundreds of thousands of
people i i traveled all over the country
during occupy
and i saw the anger people had and it
wasn't going away it was escalating
the protest died down a little bit but i
could go around anywhere talk to
somebody and they tell me the exact same
things they were mad about
i watched the tactics of these black
block far leftist type smashing windows
and getting crazier and more destructive
as time went on
and eventually got to the point where
you know they were in larger and larger
groups
it became they got they they got a new
colloquial term antifa they didn't have
that back during occupy wall street we
just called it the black bloc
you know left or anarchists because
there was no discernible group
now they fly a flag now they they shared
similar ideologies
then they started going up to trump's
you know trump rallies and i saw what
was going on with trump
the trump supporters were fed up they
were angry the divide was getting
crazier
and years ago i said that you know look
i'm reading these stories that are
predicting this stuff
based on what i've seen on the ground
over the past decade it feels like it's
happening
then we get to the point where you know
you have charlottesville
and i'm like dude i'm telling you man
this stuff's getting crazy i feel like
this
you're gonna get a tit for ted after
that then the media lies about what
trump said following
the charlottesville you know the very
fine people hoax that he didn't condemn
them he did
and that you should look it up you
should really actually said watch the
video you'll be surprised if you didn't
know that already
but then you end up with years of this
of
right-wing groups left-wing groups
fighting and it culminates in a series
of
you know major shootings deaths we get
um
i mean aaron danielson was his name in
portland he's walking down the street
some guy yells puts two bolts in his
chest this guy is then he flees the
scene
the feds find him they kill him we're at
the point where
a random shooting occurs where a guy is
killed for being trump
we got one right here here yeah shoot
him boom
dead and i was saying you see what's
going on
a year of riots buildings being smashed
we had
in oregon the attorney i believe is the
attorney general
of uh of oregon the a.g suing the
federal government
challenging their authority to defend
their own jurisdiction
it was the craziest thing to me to see
oregon's politicians telling the federal
government they had no authority
to stop people from firebombing their
building and i said at that point i was
like is this where we start seeing the
states challenge federal authority
then we heard from the boston globe
that never trump or republicans and
democrats staged a war game
where john podesta top democrat hillary
clinton type guy
that you know in her circle actually
said it would be better for the west
coast to secede from the union than
allow trump to win
and then trump didn't win and what do we
get
the capital gets stormed by trump
supporters i'm not going to pretend like
it's the
most egregious you know like armed
groups we're like marching on dc
they're trying to compare to the war of
1812 like the british soldiers storming
in come on calm down
but it still is one of the most dramatic
escalations we've seen in this
and if i was reading this stuff years
ago thinking this was going to happen
and we're here now i'm surprised there
are still people who think
nothing is going to happen from this the
media is going nuts
smearing trump supporters they're not
going to just sit back and say okay i
guess we're evil
well so the question now comes to
will there be someone
to fill that void
because i think part of the problem was
i mean there did tend to see be a
certain
looking to the person more than to the
ideal that you stand for and
uh i mean it's understandable if that's
the only person you feel
is speaking for you so now where where
does
it pivot um you know as we're looking at
the second impeachment which probably
the goal is so that he can't
run again right so you squash that and
then
um you know all the talk that you've
we've been
reading about uh reprogramming and
you know the truth and reconciliation
commissions right so
you you see that
there's trying to be a breakup right of
what is most feared from their angle
and that'll be interesting to see where
that void is
filled and who that person is or
that group is before anything can really
again get get that traction to do
something
that is uh going to take this
past a tipping point they're they're
pushing more censorship
you know we've had uh i think it was
msnbc host saying people should be
i don't know if it was msnbc i think it
was uh cnn what
they were saying banned facebook
outright it was msnbc
they were like i think it was
scarborough saying you provide nothing i
could be getting wrong so
forgive me if i'm picking the wrong
person thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you